なるほどー、六面とエイジとそらちいは＿＿＿
ﾋﾟｰ
やめろーーーー！！！
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと、六面しゃ＃＄％の六面、、、
お茶、好きですか？お茶大好き！僕も、大好き！
お茶、大好…　チーーン（拝むときの音）
というわけでお茶をたくさん買ってみました。
結構ね、買ったよ
あれ、爽健美茶は？え、爽健美茶なくね？
ちょっと六面、爽健美茶買ってきて
爽健美茶買ってきて笑
その間に説明しとく笑
なんか他になさそうなやつあったら買ってきて
綾鷹もないよ
ねえパクらないでお願い
六面財布だけは許して
え、絶対一万円札とか盗むじゃん
え、待って、絶対一万円札盗るでしょ
もうついてくわそこまで
まって絶対盗るでしょ
はい、というわけで、ここにいろんなお茶を準備しました
僕はジュースをここ三ヶ月飲んでいない
つまり僕の喉は完全に肥えています。うん
お茶の味の違いなんて一目瞭然
目隠しをして、僕がテキトーにお茶を飲むんですけども、
どれのお茶かを当ててみようと思います
多分ヨユーでいけると思ってるんですけども、
ちょっと味見味見
ヘルシア...
ヘルシア緑茶とかわかりやすいと思うんですけどね
うわー、苦い
麦茶
うまい
十六茶W
なんとも言えんな...
伊右衛門茶
奥深い味わいだ
黒烏龍茶
やべ
何も分かんねー
お〜いお茶
あら
十六茶
飲みやすい
黄金烏龍茶
黒烏龍茶より薬っぽいな
生茶
んーーーーーーーーーー
やべ、やべーな
難しい
これ十六茶違いあるの？これ
ここの十六茶が全然わかんない
あ、わかるわかる、オッケー、ここはいけるここはいける
だいたいわかってきました
うえーーーーーーーーーーーーい
うわーーーーーーーーーーーー！
この五人を追加します
烏龍茶、綾鷹、玄米茶、爽健美茶、特茶
ちょっと烏龍茶飲んでみます
ふっ
綾鷹飲みます
ちょっと苦いんだよね
玄米茶
なんか玄米茶と十六茶がすごい似てる
苦いよね？ヘルシア苦いよね
特徴掴まなきゃ
苦いな
お〜いお茶は美味しいんだよ
ルールは簡単です
六面がテキトーに一個チョイスして、僕に飲ませる
ガキ使形式で、
ハズレって言ってもいい
んでどんどん絞っていくっていう作戦もあり
とりあえずこれが何かっていうのを当てた時点で勝ちです
じゃあ、宜しくおねがいします
いやー、難しいな
ねえなんかすごい嫌な予感がするんだけど
うわーーーーー！
これだ　どれ？
入れました
そうです
わかりました　じゃあ当てに行きます
まずは臭いから入るんすよ
玄米茶的な？
え？
え、あってる？
え、待って待ってわかんない
いただきます
まじかー
なんかなんとも言えないとこ突いたでしょこれ
これはね、むずいよ
ひとまず、
烏龍茶系ではありません
あってますか？　あってます
おっけいおっけい
烏龍茶系ではない
ちょっと苦いんだよなぁ
ちょっと苦いんだよなぁ麦茶ではないです
正解です　おっけいおっけい
絞っていこうどんどん
ヘルシア、爽健美茶ではない
正解です
結構あと少ない？
９！？
待って、あー待って
これも烏龍茶だね
うーわまじかこれ
ちょっとこれまじでむずかしいんだけど
えっとね
十六茶じゃないな
正解です
本当に？よしよしよしよし
あと６本
うえー、まじ？
あ、あ、あ、
綾鷹ではないっしょ
正解です
おーしおしおしおし
綾鷹はね濃いからね味が
え、俺すごくない？結構
すごい
すごいっしょ
玄米茶でもない気がすんだよね
なんだっけあと残り
あの、
まてーーーーーーー！まてか
うわ
お〜いお茶の線はないと思うんだよ
ほう
お〜いお茶美味しいから
うん　なんか甘い感じがしたから
うん
お〜いお茶ではありません
残念！！！
正解です
え、お〜いお茶？
お〜いお茶です
うそだーーーーー
ほんまや
えーーー、いけると思ったんだけどなーーー
惜しかった